أنا واحدة من آلهة
الأظافر الطويلة ، لقد كان مجتمع السيدات ذوات الأظافر الطويلة
جزءًا من حياتي
عمليًا طوال حياتي ، السيدة الأولى
هي زوجة القس
[تصفيق]
تقليديا السيدات الأوائل لديهن قبعات كبيرة
وأظافر قصيرة وأنا '  أنا سيدة أولى ذات
أظافر طويلة وتقاليد ساحرة
لا تعرفني ، فلماذا أقوم بقص
أظافري للكنيسة ولكن لا يمكنني أن
أكون من أنا ما الذي سأفعله
لأي شخص يجلس على أي من هذه
الأدوار  الجميع هو شخص ما في
كنيسة فريزين هيل المعمدانية ،
وملعقة أخت إلهة الظفر الطويلة تمامًا مثل
أي شخص آخر
[موسيقى]
تيلا نتركها في الكنيسة التي نمتلكها كما
تفعل ماريا أظافري لمدة
خمس سنوات تقريبًا
كل أسبوع أذهب لمدة أربعة إلى  خمس
ساعات لإنجاز أظافري عندما تفتح
الأرضية تفتح أبوابها لنا
جميعًا لنتحد معًا ،
هذا هو مجتمعنا الذي كنت أقوم به
منذ 23 عامًا تقريبًا منذ أن كنت صغيرًا ،
كنت أعرف بالفعل أنني مختلفة ، لقد
ساعدني ذلك بالتأكيد  التعرف على م  ص
فتيات خرجت في الثمانينيات من القرن الماضي كمتحولين
جنسيًا وكان من الصعب جدًا
بالنسبة لي أن أكون منبوذًا من المجتمع
أعرف ما هو الرفض وأنا أعرف
كيف أشعر
أني خلقت ملاذًا آمنًا للفتيات
وكنت بحاجة إلى أن
نكون أفراد أسرة  سوف يسألني
أسئلة مثل كيف تفعل أي شيء
أقوم بتنظيف الألواح الخشبية الخاصة بي ، وأقوم بتنظيف الفرن الخاص بي ،
وأضع جهات الاتصال في مكانها ، ولم أقم
بلصقها على أنها نمت ، وهكذا أعرف كيف أستخدمها
عندما نكون في العالم  يقول الناس
أشياء بذيئة ، بعضهم يهمس ، إنها وقحة للغاية ،
إنها مؤلمة ، لكن يمكنني التحدث إلى ماريا ، فأنا
مقتنع بأنها لا تدرك القوة
التي تتمتع بها في قدرتها على تحويل
روح الشخص إلى أظافر ، وعندما
أغادر هناك يبدو الأمر وكأنني على ما يرام
أظافرك تبدو جميلة
، أشعر بالجمال ، لقد تم إحيائي ، أنا
مشحون ، دعنا نذهب ، إنه مثل الجنة ،
أنت تعلم أنك تضحك أنك تضحك أنك تتحدث
عن شخص آخر حول هذا وهذا وأنا
أحب أن أكون هنا أشخاص يتحدثون
لغات مختلفة ولكننا جميعًا نتحدث بشكل
مختلف  اللغة التي نعيشها جميعًا  هذا
هنا أنا أحب هؤلاء الفتيات ،
إنهم الأخوات الذين ليس لديّ ستة
أشقاء وهؤلاء هم النساء في
حياتي مجتمعنا في الصالون
حيث أذهب لاستعادة موجو الخاص بي إذا للتحدث
وهذا ما نفعله  عندما نجتمع ،
نساعد بعضنا البعض في
رؤية أخواتي آلهة الأظافر الطويلة يجلسن
في مقعدتي في الكنيسة هي التجربة المدهشة
التي تتيح لي أيضًا معرفة أنه
خارج جدران الصالون لدينا ندعم بعضنا
البعض آلهة الأظافر الطويلة ، إنها
مجتمع من الحب
[موسيقى]